the firestorms began in
central 50 percent of global ships
[Music]
satellites have caused a global blackout
of communications and navigation systems
both russia and the us claim the other
is responsible for the players
russia both being accused of building
armed
the exodus has been rerouted to england
now a failed state london is under three
feet of water
it's still a mystery as to why oz has
directed the no pets to this area
regardless captain kimball irish graves
went ashore to rendezvous with the
contact
awesome at the drop
good
the informant has arrived
[Music]
that briefcase is
usually i know what i'm risking my neck
for
usually i don't explain myself
[ __ ]
there you are
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
irish returned to the ship with an
injured soldier a briefcase and
instructions to meet oz's men somewhere
in the seas south of europe
the plan was simple
hand over the extracted intel and await
the next set of orders from oz
but after discovering the true
intentions behind it irish had a change
of heart
irish
you traitor
oh
how much does the no pets pay you to
[ __ ] over your home country
my loyalty is with the refugees on this
boat
that includes you now
irish better 20 clicks out i think you
better take a look at something
listen
if you give oz that case
that [ __ ] terrorist will start world
war three
that's what they always say pack
believe that [ __ ] if you want to
but i know what i'm fighting for
irish had originally joined oz because
he agreed with the need for no pets to
unify if they were ever going to have a
place in this new world
the main difference being that oz thinks
this can only happen if the old world
dies
he wants a war
he wants america and russia to burn each
other to the ground
as a marine irish saw firsthand what
happened to civilians during times of
war
he knows that by pushing a war like this
that the no pets would end up being
taken down alongside with them
oz and irish are both fighting for the
same thing
no pet survival
but are doing so through very different
means
[ __ ] one was trying to stay out of
america in russia's reach
and the other was actively trying to
manipulate them
this is what the intel in that briefcase
was all about
coordinates to an american secret the
russians wanted
bait to draw the superpowers into an
all-out war we don't have enough about
power i don't think we have a choice
head straight into that storm that's a
category 5 sir
ah
that's home field advantage
oz's men are now hovering above the ship
sensing that the deal was off
they opened fire
irish orders is meant to steer the ship
directly towards the incoming storm to
use it as cover
as men started flooding onto the deck of
the ship
a battle ensued between the two factions
yes
uh
[Music]
cavend hid downstairs with the other
refugees
but eventually the fight came to them
the watertight door that was shielding
them suddenly exploded off its hinges
a blood-soaked soldier came barreling in
and found what he was looking for
leverage
irish's seven-year-old son omar
witnessing this kevin knew something had
changed in him
over the last 13 months through
everything he had seen
he wasn't thinking like a journalist
anymore
he was thinking like a notepad
and now there was a notepad child that
needed his help
kevin is no soldier but he ran off to
the man anyway
suddenly he heard the american soldier
that irish had shot in london clayton
pokowski
he was still handcuffed to the bed
promising to help kavan didn't see that
he had much of a choice but to trust
this man
plus he had the kind of look in his face
that he'd seen in a number of other
specialists that he'd met along this
journey
pakowski managed to save irish's son
but it cost him his life
on top of this
oz's men managed to successfully extract
the intel from the briefcase
after a year of traveling with the no
pets
caven found the answer he was looking
for
the no pets are everything people say
they are
smugglers
sinners
saints
and so much more
the world created the non-patrioted
and then blamed them for its problems
but now this task force might be the
very key to saving it
[Music]
when the smoke cleared
kavan and the crew could all see the
look in the captain's eyes
oz had to be stopped from setting fire
to the world
irish had gone from marine to nopat
but he was still just a soldier taking
orders
now
it was his time
to lead
only one way to stop this war
that's to get in the middle of it
put a call out to any notepad who will
listen
36 hours
get ready
to fight
[Music]
you